- Hello Believe Nation,
I'm Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe,
and I believe that entrepreneurs are going
to solve all of the
world's major problems.
I started the Mentor
Me series with the goal
to try to learn from people
who've done a lot more than us.
People who have done amazing things,
that by spending a little
bit more time with them,
hopefully some of their
values, their belief systems,
their way of thinking seeps into us,
to help us become the
best version of ourselves.
So to help you on your journey today,
we're going to learn
from Brendon Burchard,
and some of his best advice on motivation.
Mentor me Brendon.
Rule number one is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always guys as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
And when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself too.
Enjoy.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- Why is it sometimes you're
so motivated and driven,
you're excited to go and do something.
And other days you can't
tear yourself off the couch
away from the fifth season of Netflix.
What's the difference?
Why is it some people are
so much more successful
because they have that drive, that hunger,
that ambition, that clarity?
And others struggle over and
over and over to get ahead?
The whole thing comes down
to, as you know, motivation.
But most people don't know
where motivation really comes from.
And we think hopefully one day,
we'll just have motivation.
You know, we'll wake up and be motivated.
But my favorite metaphor to
teach people is this one,
the power plant doesn't have
energy, it generates energy.
In the same way we don't have motivation,
we generate motivation.
And once you understand
the science of motivation,
when you understand where
motivation actually comes from,
now you know how to
cultivate it, and grow it.
And that's what I spent the last 20 years
of my life researching and studying.
The first thing that sparks
motivation is ambition.
Ambition is that desire
for something more.
I know that's so simple,
but hold on a second.
Because most people's ambition
is set too low for themselves.
They settled down on their ambition
because one time they were disappointed.
One time, somebody made fun of them.
Maybe their spouse, their partner,
their girlfriend, their boyfriend,
somebody around them doesn't support them
and cheer them on when they have ideas,
and so now their ambitions and
the major areas of their life
are actually pretty low.
And if I could tell anybody anything
to get more motivation,
first get more ambition.
Dream again my friend.
Be okay that your dreams and
your vision for yourself,
for your emotional
reality, for your health,
for your finances, for
how much money you have,
for what you contribute to the world.
You have to dream of that again.
You have to lay awake in bed
and think about what you desire and want.
And not just on New Year's once a year,
every single day think,
"What do I really desire?
"What do I really want?"
Your ambitions must stay in front of you
to keep that flame of motivation going.
Never lose hope.
That you have a single breath
within your body right now
and that you are alive
in this moment, is hope.
That you can see all these people
walking on the streets smiling, is hope.
That all these entrepreneurs are posting
their art online every single
day now, there is hope there.
That there is a single
person out in this world
who's soul is still burning
alive with love, is hope.
You know it's so easy during these days
when sometimes there's darkness,
when you see all this
negative media coverage,
or maybe you have a series of bad days,
or a series of bad weeks,
or your lucky break just isn't coming,
or you've been fighting for that dream,
you just don't sense any of that progress
that you just so need to feel
still enlivened and engaged,
and enthusiastic about something.
Or, somebody breaks up with
you, or you lose your job,
or something happens with your health.
Look, that's part of life,
is there's going to be so many
struggles and disappointments,
challenges, setbacks, dark days,
and part of sustaining and
making through all of that
is maintaining hope.
And that hope isn't something
that just, you know,
some airy fairy concept.
It is a psychological need to
believe that we can endure.
A psychological need to believe
that we can not only endure,
but we can succeed and we can thrive,
and we can have our way in the world
so that we can accomplish our dreams,
so that we can make influence,
so we can make our own difference.
To have hope we have to
stay persistent. Persistent.
You know, to keep at it
no matter what, you know.
If we've got our perspective
in mind, we've got our plan,
we've got to be persistent.
To keep working towards it.
You know, there were so many times
that I almost stopped doing these videos.
There are so many times that I thought,
"Well, I'm not going
to write another book."
There are so many times I thought,
"No one cares about my blog posts.
"No one cares about my Facebook posts.
"No one cares about my YouTube show.
"No one cares about me. Oh, woe is me."
Look, we can all sit on the couch,
eat a bunch of potato chips,
watch stupid television,
and feel sorry for ourselves.
That does not contribute to our aliveness,
it does not contribute to our connection
with those we love and care for,
and it does not contribute
to the things that we create,
and ultimately give to the world.
So we've got to say, "You
know what, this is not what,
"when are we going to persist at sitting
"and eating potato chips and watching TV?"
That's not going to be good.
What we have to do, is
persist towards our dreams.
What are the three things
you can accomplish this day,
this very day? And tomorrow?
And start moving towards your dreams?
Everyday wake up with the intention,
"I'm going to do at least three
things to move myself forward
"to something that matters."
At least three things.
Everybody can do that.
Just pick, "What are the
three things I'm going to do
"to move my life forward this day?
"Who do I need to reach out
to to be able to move forward?
"What can I read or study
online to move forward?
"What can I do?"
Just one simple request,
one simple movement,
one simple step to move forward,
and persist at that, over
and over and over again.
And that's how things change.
What is it that's going to
actually change somebody's life?
It's not removing their limiting beliefs.
And I know that sounds
silly, but it's like,
if you just put less pressure
on the brake in your car,
it doesn't mean you're
going to speed up, right?
Your foot's still on the brake.
If you're always focusing on these things
that are limiting you, you're
always going to be limited
just because your relative
weight of importance
and duration of your
focus and your attention
is on these limiting things.
And it's a time in our culture,
just like in our psychology,
in our study of psychology,
we've got to move from mental
illness to mental health.
We've got to get you to move
from your limiting beliefs,
into something bigger and
greater and grand about yourself.
We've got to stop you
focusing on all the reasons
that you're a mouse in life,
and start focusing on why you're a lion.
Why you have something within you
that's more bold and powerful and profound
than you've ever even knew.
So what we have to do is change
what I call your dominant
frame of attention and focus.
Most people's dominant frame,
they're giving that relative
weight of importance
to those things that limit them.
And I say, "You know what, this year,
"this next year has to be the year for you
"that you're limitless."
That you're going to go, "Okay, enough."
I mean how far have you
gotten in your life now
where you're just
constantly beating yourself
and berating yourself and
worrying about your limits?
And worrying about all these things,
of all the reasons that
you have to be worried,
to be weak, to be less than you are.
You know it's like when
Mary Ann Williamson
said so long ago, "You
are not serving the world
"by playing small."
And you're not serving the
world by constantly focusing
on your limiting beliefs
and trying to remove them.
Look, you will always have insecurity.
I know that's really motivating,
but you're always going to have it.
I work with some of the top professionals
in every given field.
Some of the best athletes in the world,
some of the best well-known celebrities
and many of the people who
are the best performers
in any given industry.
And I can tell you,
they still have their
doubts and their fears.
They still have times when they wake up
and they're just like,
"I don't know what to do with myself."
That doesn't ever go away,
and that's great because it's
part of the human condition
that also makes us
humble, it makes us real,
it makes us check ourselves.
And I'm not saying that, you know,
we all have to go around being
happy optimists all the time.
But I will share with
you, if you didn't know,
optimists are much more
capable of changing the world
than pessimists are.
It's not a guess, it's proven by science.
And what do we mean by that?
Optimism is one of the most studied thing,
in the psychology literature, period.
It's one of the most studied traits.
Optimists are more likely to
face a problem than pessimists.
'Cause pessimists go,
"Oh, I can't change it,
"I can't do anything about it,
"it's going to be that way forever,
"it's a pervasive problem and
I don't have a control of it."
An optimist says, "Well, I
can probably handle that.
"We can change that too."
In other words, pessimists
tend to avoid problems
that need to be changed,
and optimists tend to confront them
and move forward, and
do something about it.
That's pretty profound,
and it's pretty proven now.
So yeah, I'm saying, you know,
while not all of us can go
around being happy-go-lucky,
and avoiding all of our limits,
I'm also saying, you know what,
maybe it is time that
we focus on those things
that we can change.
Focus on something that's
bigger than ourselves,
and our own little
insecurities and worries.
And I think that's the
challenge right now,
with so many people saying,
"Limiting beliefs, limiting beliefs."
Look, they're there.
You're going to have them.
The question is, are they
going to win the day?
Your peers have a lot to do
with the setting long-term,
of your health, of your
drive, of your success,
of your social economic status.
The people that you hang out with
impact your life tremendously.
So your environment, do
you have the right people?
If you don't have great people around you,
I always tell people,
go to a seminar, get in
personal development,
go volunteer, go do things
with your church group.
But just get out there with
people who are like-minded,
who want to grow, and want to give.
'Cause if you're around people
who want to grow and give
all day long, you become stronger,
and you contribute more too.
And suddenly, you find more
motivation and fulfillment.
Here's a very simple thing you can do
to re-program your mind.
Create a sheet of two simple
things, very simple things.
I want you to write five questions down,
that you're going to ask yourself
three or four times a day.
Five questions that are positive,
for yourself in general.
Everyday you're going to
wake up in the morning,
you're going to read these
questions to yourself,
you're going to answer 'em.
You're going to read 'em,
Every morning.
Then at lunch, read the
questions, answer 'em.
At night, read the questions, answer 'em.
These can be questions like,
what can I feel incredibly
grateful for right now?
How could I surprise or flirt
with somebody right now?
How could I have fun right now?
Positive things like that, right?
How could I demonstrate love
or excellence right now?
Ask these questions in the morning,
ask in the afternoon, ask 'em at night.
By asking these positive
questions over and over,
I mean you just do this for 30 days,
you're going to recognize
a total shift in your life.
Just simple questions.
But you're giving them weight,
by focusing on 'em three
times during the day.
You're having duration by focusing on it
three times during the day over 30 days.
Your mind starts to re-shift it's gears,
to give automatic ease to
answering those questions
and living in that mindset,
versus an undirected, unconscious mindset.
Second thing on that sheet,
or those things you can do,
five questions first,
second thing I want you to do,
is come up with three words
that describe your ideal self.
Just, three words you know?
Mine are for example,
present, excited and bold.
So I'm going to focus on those questions
three times a day as well.
What I do is I put 'em on my iPhone,
and they come up as an alarm,
three different times during the day.
Just my phone buzzes, and
those words are there.
I'm like, "Oh right, I'm that guy."
I got to focus on being
that guy versus whatever,
I might be in a bad mood.
I'm like aah!
You know, completely detached,
and I look, I'm like, "Dude,
no I'm an excited person.
"Break that thought, get back into this.
"Got it, this is who I am."
And now that might sound so simpy, simple.
Simpy? Simpy.
That sounds so simple, but guess what?
People won't do the discipline.
They are so frustrated
with their mind because
they haven't done the
conscience discipline
to re-program it.
The first idea is to emotionally
engage with that dream,
each morning of your life.
See, a lot of people
don't actually struggle
with the discipline part, in
terms of the doing the thing.
It's that, they are not getting
revved up to do the thing.
In other words we got a
problem with motivation,
not necessarily just discipline.
We have a problem with,
that once in awhile,
you hit it, you do it, you do the work.
But a lot of times you fall off,
because you're not
emotionally engaged in it.
It's like, if you want
a lot of discipline,
you need a high level
of emotional connection
and focus on that thing that
you want to work towards.
So every morning what I want you to do,
is just start a new
visualization practice.
When you wake up in the
morning, close your eyes,
think about the dream, the aspiration,
the thing that you're
really after in life,
and just visualize it.
And really get yourself
emotionally attached,
emotionally engaged with it.
Think about how great it will feel,
for you to have that
thing, or be that thing,
or contribute that thing,
to make that difference.
Just think about, allow it to well up
in your heart a little
bit, get excited about it.
Remember the dream.
That's why we get away from discipline,
because we're so busy with
the chaos of the world,
that we emotionally are no
longer attached in a way
that our brain says,
"Hey man, focus on this.
"It's important to remember."
So if your heart is disengaged,
it's difficult to stay disciplined.
So every morning make it a practice
to actually just imagine the payoff,
the benefit, the contribution, the art,
the thing that you do, and
are doing, and do contribute.
If you can do that more often,
you'll be more fired up, and
you'll stay back on track.
You have to actually show up every day,
and inch yourself forward
toward these dreams.
And not only show up every day,
and once in awhile inch yourself.
I mean every day, you have
to actually take an action
that moves you forward,
not just research, not just thinking.
Look, the power of intention is great,
but without any initiative it's dead.
Right? A dream is great,
but without any movement it's dead.
You have to be moving towards every day.
You can send an email every day,
you can make a call every day,
you can write something every day,
you can create something every day,
you can contribute something every day.
But it has to be daily,
otherwise it will never become actualized.
The highest performers in
the world didn't get there
'cause they were lucky,
they worked at it longer
than everyone else.
They had a better work ethic.
And it's not that they
necessarily always worked harder,
they worked smarter because
they were doing the research,
they were taking the time to visualize
how they would be distinct, different,
how they would survive the tough times.
They really kept at it.
Keep every single day momentum going,
and if you don't do
that, there's no chance.
In the psychology literature,
expectancy means it's a belief
that not only is it possible for you,
but that you can do it.
That you have the personal
control, the self-reliance,
the autonomy, the thing that says,
"You know what, I believe in
my ability to figure this out,
"and I know I can move the
needle of progress forward
"in going this."
In other words, you expect
your dreams to happen,
and you expect that you have the strength
and the confidence to make it happen.
The challenge is, I know so
many people in the world,
who sometimes they have the dream
but the ambition goes away
'cause of other people around them.
Sometimes they have the
ambition and the dream,
but they don't really believe
in themselves deep down inside.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know, what did
you take from this video
that you're going to
immediately apply somehow
to your life or to your business?
Leave it down in the comments below,
I'm super curious to find out.
I also wanted to give a quick
shout out to Oskar Andermo.
Oskar, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word, and doing the
review on your YouTube channel.
I really, really appreciate it man.
And I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book.
- Today's book report is The
One Word by Evan Carmichael.
- Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.